on a fini notre tournage et ses îles et
au centre de 9h45 10 heures et là il ya
une classe qui est donc en récréation et
qui nous sera temps on avait vu ses
carrés mais c'est carré était vide et à
ce moment là il a les enfants qui sont
d'ordre ils sont assis au moment je fais
la photo et ça fait bizarre donc il ya
ma collègue avec lamerat qui fait des
images et j'ai encore une fois la
directrice à côté de moi parce qu'on
vient de faire du direct ensemble et
sommes et je la regardais et je demande
très sincèrement est-ce que je suis le
seul à être mal à l'aise
il ya un moment de silence et elle me
répond que non la mal au coeur elle
aussi parce que le rôle de la maternelle
quand on a 3 ans quand ils ont quatre
ans et la socialisation s'y être avec
les autres et là la mission de l'école
maternelle n'est plus remplie c'est la
scène se fait extrêmement rapidement
mais on à l'auxiliaire qui est avec avec
les enfants dont leur carré et c'est
tout le monde se lève à l'est on saute
donc arrêt c'est des jeux d'enfants en
fait d'aider des animations va sauter
dans le carré on s'assoit on reçoit
lèvres c'est une cour de récréation les
enfants jouent entre eux ils rigolent
ils voient leurs copains que l'autre
côté de leur car et du coup c'est un peu
l'enjeu pour eux ils sont pas
traumatisés à ce moment là l'image est
choquant pour nous mais eux joue la
comme peuvent jouer des enfants de 3,4
en quoi il ya plusieurs photos qui ont
été publiées sur mon compte twitter
la première où on voit les croise et aux
alentours de 8h15 quand les enfants
arrivent avec leurs parents avant
d'arriver en classe il accueille tous
les enfants du même niveau
quand je dis tous les amplis n'avait pas
beaucoup puisque y avait que 21 élèves
sur toute l'école maternelle donc c'est
très peu et donc quand les parents
lâcher leurs enfants les enfants
s'asseyait sur ces croix et une fois que
la classe entre guillemets était
complète l'instit prenait ses enfants
qui étaient assis sur les toits pour
aller en classe il ya un élément qui
nous a marqué c'est que il ya une petite
qui comme dans toute rentrée où toute
reprise d'école pleurait le chagrin de
la rentrée et il y avait il y avait une
assistante qui s'est un petit peu énervé
mais derrière sa visière et derrière son
masque
donc c'était pas perceptibles pour les
enfants mais on a entendu l saint gatien
de ne pas pouvoir aller faire un câlin
cette petite qui pleurait ça a été le
premier
premier moment où on dit oh c'est
bizarre c'est vraiment bizarre quand un
gamin de 3 ans pleure et que l
assistante et la maîtresse ne peuvent
pas aller lui faire un câlin pour la
rencontre la réconforter alors que les
parents sont partis quoi là il était aux
alentours de 9h30 on est côté
élémentaire donc avec des cp ce1
on suit donc ce début de journée où là
aussi tout est étrange parce que parce
qu'il ya une distance d'un mètre
cinquante entre chaque table et il ya ce
marquage au sol ce balisage
voilà donc certaines début de début de
classe l'idée c'était pas de reprendre
les cours tout de suite c'est
lorsqu'elle nous a expliqué on prend le
temps d'expliquer aux enfants tout ce
qui changera on ne se passe pas les
stylos on ne passe pas les livres
évidemment c'est pas de calais et e le
matin basse et c'est le temps de parole
ont fait tourner ont la parole des
enfants pour la pour sentir un peu où
ils en sont psychologiquement après deux
mois de confinement le retour à l'école
dans une école qui connaissent pas là on
était avec des cp ce1 c'est une classe
ne fonctionne pas comme ça d'habitude il
ya des cp d'un côté des soins de l'autre
les cp était avec la maîtresse décès
loin donc ils n'avaient pas leurs
maîtresses laisser loire n'était pas
dans la classe qu'ils avaient en temps
normal donc tous les repères avait été
bousculé